j'ai terriblement envie de me refaire le
sexe c'est pitié mais vous qui avez dit
ça c'est vous
qui vous plaît le jour nous avons reçu
d'aucune chirurgienne esthétique
charmant oui regardez attentivement le
visage de de benjamin ses lèvres ses
paupières et tout ça et après l'émission
d'habitude de benjamin vous savez il
part très vite hélas pas du tout il
n'est pas du tout partie est allée dans
les loges il était très agité très
fébrile s'est approché de moi et biome
d'ailleurs que l'on peut en témoigner il
a dit oh là là vraiment donné envie de
me refaire le thème le sexe parce qu
elle était spécialisée parties intimes
aussi bien les sexes de femme que les
sexe d'homme mais donc ils étaient
formels il a dit qu'il avait très envie
de faire ça et suggéré refaire le sexe
alors on n'est pas réservé un devis
c'est alors je vais vous dire je me suis
vous voyez votre sexe pâtissent à cause
de votre
nom mais ses blagues et sert à rien je
me suis renseigné en fait l'opération
qui consisterait à faire un
agrandissement du pénis envoie le
problème c'est que sade efficace que au
repos comme ça c'est pas au repos a bien
sûr c'est que vous reposer jamais
en fait si on pousse en fait l'opération
ça ne modifie pas l'érection de mon
intérêt sera donc j'ai téléphoné pour
saigner excellence et des
3000 euros et en plus il vous faut vous
foutent de la grèce dans le mode de
petites et les vieux
[Rires]
moi je le savais
c'est sympa les gens là
bas c'est benjamin et
j'ai un copain qui l'a fait selon lui
d'abord merci c'est un échec cuisant
c'est pas vrai c'est qu'avec ces matches
c'est que benoît dubois benoît dubois de
star à qui la famille et ma mère était
vraiment il détaille ses cadres il était
clinique champs elysées ou qui m'ont dit
lui prenne de la grèce dans la fesse ils
l'ont injectée dans le nid et après miss
horrible le médecin avec des gants c'est
comme ça
tu sais exactement c'est comme les
boulettes ou quoi est parti pour que la
grèce a il fait ça et l'arrêtent sahir
minutes forme il attend toi tu es là tu
es ridicule tu es comme ça interesse a
jusqu'à une prévenance pareil et il m'a
dit franchement ça dure et ça
c'est pas très bien comme ça fait sens
pour moi non effectivement à six mois à
peu près à lui la paix oui ça
franchement six mois sans rigoler
franchement je préfère avec tom castaldi
un peu comme si j'avais pas vu celle de
catane ans il peut le faire si tu l'as
vu toi même si moi un arrêt suivant
gazette
ouais
des dires il a été quelques la vue je
dis la vérité tu as vu jeu pardon mais
dit les vérités voire des sexes et
c'est sûr qu'ils avaient plus au top que
de musée
non mais
les yeux permet donc
c'est parce que tu as mieux voilà c'est
tout c'est parce que tu allais
qu'auraient certains ceinture et puis
quoi choquer l'occasion de le dire mais
il a vu une photo non j'ai pas vu que
t'étais un poil tout le temps normal
moyenne actuellement je voyais ça
beaucoup plus petit non non a demandé à
valérie pascale avis aussi brillamment
du coup elle peut faire cette route
cela dit nous complexer pas les gens ce
n'est pas grave du tout d'avoir un micro
s'exercer
sur non ce n'est pas une maladie
maladie on
découvrait voilà de la masa les pages
du livre
c'est en fait tousser
[Applaudissements]
complique je suis pas les rôtis la
raison battue aura des
gens chez eux qui doit paraître sinon
nous soulage tu vois josiane
secretstory la micro pénis
jamais c'est bien qu'il n'ait pas
[Applaudissements]
on a un peu titillé
[Rires]
oui ça n'est pas d'accord on l'a vue de
doper nu ça pendait
[Applaudissements]
c'était une course
d'hommes amis c'était rien
c'était l'europe
[Applaudissements]